as the Marvel Cinematic Universe finally
found this Adam warlock entertainment
news sites we got discovered claims that
they have an anonymous source with
insider knowledge and that source says
Marvel Studios executives are eyeing
stranger things breakout star take a
Montgomery to portray Adam warlock in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 this
undisclosed source also saves Montgomery
is actually one of many actors at the
studio is placed on his warlock wish
list so hardcore fans of his shouldn't
go screaming on social media that he's a
shoo-in for the part the insider also
stated that casting for guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 hasn't even officially
begun as of mid july 2019 though they
did share that Montgomery is likely to
be in the running when's marvel invited
director James Gunn finally gets the
gears on the long-awaited three call
turning third-party reports claim that
casting for the third guardians movie
will begin in November so it seems
plausible that Marvel could start making
a list of contenders a few months in
advance it should be noted that Marvel
hasn't actually confirm the presence of
Adam warlock in guardians of the galaxy
volume 3 so we're not entirely sure if
the character will even be a part of the
story talk amongst a Marvel community
claims the atom that artificially
created being meant to serve as a
perfect human and the pinnacle of
evolution will somehow cross paths with
the guardians as they search for that
Lost member Gamora after the past
version of herself or vanished during
the battle with Panos and Avengers
endgame the reason for this theory is
down to two things a mid-credits scene
from guardians of the galaxy vol 2 in
which the sovereign High Priestess Aisha
reveals that she created a powerful
being to destroy the guardians I think I
shall call him
Werdum and then there's guns Paz
mentioned that Adam was meant to appear
in guardians vol 2 but would instead pop
up in a later franchise instalments in
2017 gun discourage fans from believing
that Adam would definitely be in
guardians vol 3 so that clearly hasn't
stopped them from speculating about the
exact opposite Adam warlock SEM tu debut
feels inevitable and there's certainly a
long time coming given that he was even
in talks to appear in the super-sized
superhero and sample Avengers endgame
such an appearance would have been
appropriate since adam has had a
complicated history with endgames main
antagonist Santos first partnering with
the mad Titan that destroy his eventual
evil alter ego Magus then serving as his
biggest rival
and game screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely ultimately
felt like it would be too much of a
quote backbend to introduce Adam in the
film so that seedling of a thought never
sprouted Montgomery would be a nice fit
for Adam warlock as a 24 year old Ossie
actor has had experience in the
superhero arena before previously
playing the Red Ranger in 2017 S Power
Rangers reboots he may face fierce
competition in the fight to portray an a
warlock if he's truly in consideration
for it of course Zac Efron who recently
stunned the Netflix is extremely wicked
shockingly evil and vile has also been
rumored to be up for the role in
guardians vol 3
even if Montgomery does lose out on the
gig the stranger thing star could very
well be a part of the superhero
franchise in a totally different
capacity many fans are hoping that once
Marvel Studios reboots the x-men
franchise in the aftermath of Disney's
acquisition of 20th Century Fox
Montgomery will become the new Wolverine
a younger version of the character
famously played by fellow Aussie Hugh
Jackman at this stage is soldier
speculation but one thing is clear
daga Montgomery is having one hell of a
summer perfect for your amazing check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more loop of videos about the
MCU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
you